Hey everyone! Today we're learning English with
Dua Lipa and Ellen. By the way, in case you're new
here we help you to learn fast English without
getting lost, without missing the jokes and
without subtitles. Just like Zainab who says that
she watches our lessons every day and her English
skills have improved in just three months. So if
that sounds good to you don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and the bell down below so that
you don't miss a single one of our new lessons.
Do you find it difficult to understand fast
speaking natives? Then I highly recommend
our Fluent with Friends Course. In this 48 week
course you'll learn with the first two seasons
of Friends, you'll receive pdf power lessons
every week, vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle Global Community
and so much more. And did you know you can try it
right now for free with our 3-Part Master class?
All you have to do is click up here or down in the
description box below to learn more and sign
up now. We look forward to seeing you there.
If you enjoy learning English with The Ellen
Show then why not check out our playlist.
You can click up here or down in the description
box below to choose your next lesson.